The question that we are, for that matter, Alice, Bob, and Carol were stuck with
at the end of the previous unit was that they had only been able to find
exponential time algorithms for these 3 problems here,
and those algorithms did not show any acceptable running time.
So the question they were stuck with is, did they just not think hard enough
to find good algorithms for their problems, or are their problems intractable,
which would mean that it's not even possible or at least highly unlikely
to find a polynomial time algorithm for those problems?
And this is what we'll investigate further in this unit.
And I'm not yet going to reveal the answer to you but what I am going to tell you is that
without realizing it by asking this question, if their problems are tractable or intractable,
Alice, Bob, and Carol are currently pondering what is by many seen
as one of the toughest questions in computer science--
the famous P vs. NP problem.
And in this unit, I want to show you 4 things.
First, what these letters mean. Second, what the problem is actually all about.
So what this here means.
Third, what Alice, Bob, and Carol have actually to do with a P vs. NP problem.
And then, last but not the least, how you could become an instant millionaire.
That's not bad for one unit, is it?